Let's suppose that in a network we have three
hosts shown as squares at the edge of the
network that are connected by links with capacities as
shown. The two senders on the left can send
at rates of 10 megabits per second and 100
megabits per second, respectively. But the link to the
host on the right is only 1.5 megabits per
second. So these different hosts on the left are actually
competing for the same resources inside the network.
So the sources are unaware of each other and
also of the current state of whatever resource
they are trying to share. In this case How
much other traffic is on the network. This
shows up as lost packets or long delays and
can result in throughput that's less than the
bottleneck link, something that's also known as congestion collapse.